hello people in line for Paris oh here
oh here we go this is the prayer line
remember your right your prayer gym work
hello I have a prayer I need to get off
my chest my prayer is that I was I just
was curious about Joel Osteen and I just
wanted a prayer about pray for him is he
around right now it's the prayer print
like pralines
oh okay so yeah explain to me how it
works
explain to me how this works I'm new to
this how does it work my name is Rick
you talking in tongues right now hon I
how does it work the prayer the pray
line I need to talk to Joel Osteen it's
a very important message I have lots of
money right now I have I have over
eighty seven thousand dollars and I am
ready sorry I have eighty-three thousand
eight hundred and ninety seven dollars
right now for Joel Osteen and I'm ready
to pray let's pray together how much do
you get paid to do to answer the pray
line what sorry say it again
did you just talk in tongues are you
talking in some made-up is that is that
Klingon you talking in Klingon baby talk
I
you keep saying Ricky do you know
someone named Ricky Ricky Tata Tata what
does what does any of this mean I'm
confused is it if I were to translate
this would it be would it be like hey
don't let people into the building
during the flood because we don't want
their dirty footsteps walking on our
nice carpets I heard you the first time
yeah I heard it the first time blood of
Jesus 2015 2015 was a good year
flight news flight news battles is that
a magazine you read what are you talking
about I am so confused right now
is this supposed to be some kind of yes
oh it's a prayer line is that it's a
prayer line where you just ramble crazy
nonsense what language is this I just
I'm gonna call my translator so I can
follow the conversation
Ricky Papa Chak Ricky Tati tubby pop pop
pop touchy
Ricky Tati puppy Tommy pat pat up up up
up up Ricky ticky tacky Bucky Bucky
Bucky Tuggy
you're laughing at it cuz you know it's
funny cuz it's ridiculous that's why
you're laughing right now I just made
you laugh at your own ridiculousness you
are cracking up and remember Ricky ticky
tacky Bucky huggy buggy buggy buggy
buggy buggy you're dying
oh she said she's gonna put me up to the
next level as prayerline she's gonna
chip to toll
she's like what do you I cannot believe
what I just heard that was insane what's
amazing dodging questions by talking and
nonsense baby talk I can't believe that
people actually just start like to me
talking with time so it's so like it's
so like she's like it's the spirit
taking her my ass evangelical super
church's it's so silly we open they say
when it hits you when it hits you just
let it out and it's like sort of this
weird like improv session